- Ballet is supposed to be beautiful,
I'm gonna make it look so ugly.
(laughs)
I'm just gonna be
holding on for dear life.
(rock music)
I've been doing pole dance now
for about 10 years.
I like to do some
crossfit, and some running,
and some spinning, and
sometimes some yoga.
But mostly crossfit.
When we first started
dated, I would go boxing
like three times a week,
six months into that I found
Barre method and pilates,
and I became addicted to them.
It's more than the pole tricks,
like people see the pole
tricks and they're like,
oh my god, I'm not
strong enough to do that,
or I'm not sexy enough.
It teaches you more about yourself.
It teaches you how to use your body.
And people learn that the
impossible is possible.
It's fun because it's not just like
you're working out to work out.
You're working out because you
wanna get better at pull ups,
and you wanna get better at push ups.
It's dance, so your body
weight is what challenges you
and holds you back,
and you have more body weight.
- Oh god, now I'm really thinking about it
and I am so scared.
- I have never taken a class, but--
- But today it's going down.
- I do this with the baby a lot.
- I want to say five days a week.
- You do not work out five days a week!
- But I don't, but it's
really just like once.
- I'm excited.
- I'm not.
(laughing)
I'm truly terrified.
- Alright let's do it.
- Let's go.
- Hi, my name is Lucy,
and I am a crossfit
coach at Crossfit/Mindset
and today I am taking Kate and Jared
through a crossfit workout.
So I know Late has a good engine
and that she'll push through
the workout pretty quickly.
I've only seen Jared,
in the last three and a half, four years
that I've known him,
to work out one time.
- We're at Health LA in Los Angeles,
and today I'm gonna be
teaching an amazing pole class.
It's a great workout for anybody
no matter if you're a man or a woman
so, guys out there, give it a try.
It's dope.
- As long as you are prepared
to be out of your comfort zone
I think you're gonna do just great.
- Okay, cool.
- Cool.
- We'll see you in class.
- Great, let's do it.
- [Dance Instructor] Start
to lift your knees up,
lift right to the height of your hips,
lift, lift, so one leg at
a time is gonna come up.
Point your toes down towards
the floor with each leg.
- So first, go ahead and
give me 30 jumping jacks.
- [Jarod] Alright.
- [Lucy] And bring it up.
- Alright up onto your knee
and then lean forward into your front leg.
- [Lucy] Three, two, one, go.
Eight pull ups.
♫ It's a party put your hands up
- I don't know how I'm gonna
get to round four with those.
- [Lucy] Alright head to your bar
you've got ten front squats.
- [Dance Instructor] Rest your hands
either somewhere on your leg
or you can hold onto the barre,
wherever it feels okay for your stretch.
Raise your room-side arm up over head,
bend sideways at your waist,
keeping your chest tilted
upwards towards the ceiling.
- And put your palm
towards the ceiling, yeah.
You're really good.
- So the first move we're gonna learn
is called the firefly.
Beginner move, since
you're a beginner, okay.
One, two, three,
turn and hook your left foot,
and then you're gonna push
off, right leg in the back,
bring it up nice and sexy.
- Wait a minute,
is my hand supposed to be
slippery or something?
- No.
- Yeah, bring your chest up
so your shoulders are
right above your hips.
Good, do it eight more times
and your last thing,
press down, squeeze in one,
down, squeeze two,
down, squeeze three,
down, and four, there's that shake,
squeeze in five,
down, and six, down, seven,
down, squeeze eight.
- Shake is good!
- [Dance Instructor] Hold
that next one low and squeeze,
just squeeze in to finish.
- Alright.
- [Dance Instructor] A
little squeeze on the mat,
let it burn, you guys are almost there,
Garrick, what happened?
Come on back.
- [Lucy] Push, press.
♫ I'm tryna party all
night 'cause I'm feelin' it
Jared, adjust your feet
to be a little closer,
underneath your hips.
- One, two, three, turn
and hook the left foot,
right leg goes in back,
and then push that booty up, oh yeah.
Alright, take turns,
but that was pretty good
for the first one.
Here you can do my pole.
- She made this look so easy.
It ain't, nope.
- [Jarod] She's on the last round,
I'm only halfway through.
- [Lucy] Woo!
- [Kate] Babe, you're so
close, you're so close.
♫ The music is bumpin'
♫ The DJ is killin' it
♫ I'm tryna party all night
(Jared groans in pain)
- They're trying to kill me.
- So I'm giving him a slightly easier band
to work with for his
next couple of rounds.
- Ready?
- I'm ready.
- Should I go?
- One more, okay now.
- Two?
- Open the legs, split,
drop it, keep going,
your ass has to touch the ground.
- I am a boy, demon!
(laughing)
- Bend this knee, bend it, there you go!
Good job!
- Oh god.
- And bring it up sexy.
- Bring, F that, my hips hurt.
♫ Gettin' all sweaty
♫ The music is bumpin
♫ The DJ is killin' it
♫ I'm tryna party all
night 'cause I'm feelin' it
- There ya go.
- [Dance Instructor]
Opening up your chest,
loosen your thighs, down and up.
- It hurts, it hurts too much.
This when you're sideways.
- Oh the shaking.
- [Garrick] And you're doing squats
while on the ball of your feet.
That was driving me crazy,
because your entire thigh is on fire.
- It's fun to see what she does everyday,
and I respect her a lot
so when she says I'm tired,
I don't wanna do nothing.
- Exactly.
- I think I might believe it now.
- You're supposed to suck
when you first start.
Like, I sucked.
- Really?
- Yeah, I really did.
- Did I suck?
- You did.
- The hardest move was the
twerkin' around the pole.
You know, I love Magic Mike
and Vivica's Black Magic,
I thought, I can do it. No.
- [Lucy] I had to take his weight down,
because it was too
heavy for the movements,
just 'cause he hasn't
done it in the long time.
- You know, it feels pretty good,
what are those, endorphins?
- Yeah.
- Man, I think Jared
did really super good,
well, he's good at putting
his mind to something,
and just being like, I'm going to do this.
- Kate's super strong.
I didn't know how strong,
like she was super strong,
until she had that baby, let me tell you.
- [Garrick] There are
parts where you feel silly,
and other than that--
- [Ali] What's your review?
- 10/10, would do again.
- Wow!
- I would--
- You would?
Yeah no, because, only because--
(both laughing together)
- [Ali] When are we coming?
- I'm not coming in by myself, like,
hey, yo, where's the barre?
- No.
- No, but I would do it again though.
- [Jared] Ugh, that was terrible.
(laughing)
Kate does this every
morning at like six, almost.
(quirky, playful music)
(logo whooshes)
(hinges squeak)